my name is Kate Hansen I'm a master of
arts management student at Carnegie
Mellon currently
I'm the co-director a future tenant
every year the future tenant is staffed
by about six first-year ma'am students
that's master of arts management they
fill roles such as visual programming
performance programming print marketing
media marketing so a little bit of
everything and second year students to
second-year students are chosen as
directors it's complementary to the
program we can talk about things
theoretically all day and write papers
about them but went until you actually
do it it really is cementing those
concepts into my learning experience
future tenant is a really unique
situation eight years ago when we first
started talking about this the
Pittsburgh Cultural Trust was interested
in putting arts organizations downtown
to fill vacant storefronts to encourage
new development to encourage arts
organizations and other types of
businesses to move into the downtown
area and so we talked about it we
thought wow what a great opportunity you
know we have all these theory classes
that talk about arts management and we
have them do internships and and have
practicum experience but this is
something beyond that running their own
organization with their own board of
directors and their own community and
audiences and interfacing directly with
artists would be a tremendous
opportunity for us to be able to give
local artists a chance to show downtown
is really important it's it's given me
personally out just a world of
confidence in myself as a professional I
can say that I have experience in a lot
of different facets and and mean it oh
it's really cool to be able to hang out
with artists and interact with the
community which is what future tenant is
mostly about